Follow Lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today we'll be answering the question
how similar our Spanish and Italian,
Spanish and Italian are both members of
the romance language family,
which developed from dialects of vulgar
Latin,
which were spoken throughout the Roman
Empire.
For more information on their history
and development,
check out my video on the romance
language family right here,
like any pair of romance languages.
Spanish and Italian have a lot in common
and they are mutually intelligible to
some extent,
especially in the written form and when
spoken slowly and clearly some speakers
of Spanish and Italian report that they
are able to have extended conversations
with speakers of the other language
provided that they both speak slowly and
clearly and they stopped to clarify
unfamiliar vocabulary,
but despite their similarity,
Spanish and Italian are also different
in many ways.
Let's examine both of the languages
together and we'll see just what's
similar and different above them.
Vocabulary,
Spanish and Italian have about 82
percent lexical similarity.
That means that 82 percent of the words
in either language will have cognate
vocabulary in the other language.
Let's look at some examples of Spanish
and Italian cognates in Italian,
Jada,
dino,
and in Spanish.
How these means garden in Italian postal
Wisdom.
This means place in Italian fjord and in
Spanish,
Florida.
This means flower in Italian,
bobby Lee,
and in Spanish probably this means
probable or likely in Italian and it's
Spanish.
What this means port,
those pairs of words are quite obvious.
Cognates.
Let's look at a couple of less obvious
cognates as well.
In Italian feeding,
you in Spanish,
equal in Italian,
he avi in Spanish or in Italian?
Up ended Spanish.
Gotcha.
Now let's look at a couple of sentences
to see how many of the words are
similar.
First in Spanish is still agenda and an
Italian stone agenda on porn.
Liberal.
This means I'm reading a good book,
so when these two sentences,
all of the vocabulary is equivalent or
cognate.
Another example in Spanish,
and she took him yet in Italian ob zone,
you'll notice all these sentences mean I
need to change a little money.
The way to express need is different
than the two sentences in Spanish,
yet necessito and in Italian it's ob
zone.
Your d in Spanish,
the way to say a little is wouldn't
buckle.
In Italian,
it's wouldn't pull.
you can also say wouldn't buckle,
which is correct,
but it's more common to say,
wouldn't pull next the preposition like
have his day in Spanish and it's deep.
In Italian,
the word for money is in Spanish and
it's solid in Italian.
So in this case you can see that some of
the vocabulary is the same or
equivalent,
but not all of it.
And one more example in Spanish and in
Italian Dayville Trovata.
When a banker,
these sentences mean I need to find a
bank.
In these sentences we see need expressed
in different ways than in the last pair
of sentences.
In Spanish it's tango,
k,
in Italian it's devil,
but in Spanish it's also possible to say
table and obvious cognitive devil.
The word meaning to find is also
different.
In Spanish it's English,
but in Italian it's Audi.
Actually the Spanish word can also mean
to meet and there's a different Italian
word,
England throughout it,
which is a cognitive angle,
but it only means to meet,
not to find.
Next you can see that the words for bank
are cognates,
but interestingly they have different
gender.
In Spanish,
it's masculine,
which we can see from the article soon
and the Oh,
at the end of uncle and an Italian.
It's feminine,
which we can see from the article Una
and the a at the end of bunker.
So from these examples we can see that
there's a lot of crossover between
Spanish vocabulary and Italian
vocabulary,
but there are also some false friends to
watch out for false friends.
No,
I don't mean to face to people who talk
behind your back.
I mean words that look and sound similar
and either language and likely share a
common origin,
but they have a different meaning or
usage in each language.
For example,
in Spanish,
but on the door mean soon in Italian,
put on top means ready in Spanish.
Whether that means to keep or to guard
in Italian Guata dot,
it means to look at in Spanish means
office.
In Italian,
Oficina means workshop.
There's a different word in Italian you,
which means office in Spanish means
pregnant,
but in Italian means embarrassed.
False friends like these are a common
source of confusion for people who learn
a language that's similar to one.
They already know.
If we only look at lexical similarity,
Spanish has more in common with
Portuguese than it does with the Italian
and the Italian has more in common with
French than it does with Spanish.
In either case,
it's 89 percent lexical similarity,
but Spanish and Italian are more similar
and pronunciation than those other pairs
of languages which can sometimes lead to
more intelligibility.
Pronunciation Spanish has five.
Vowel sounds,
a e,
a.
Oh,
Italian also has these five vowels.
Sounds plus two additional ones.
Italian has to east sounds open.
He at like the in bed and closed.
He a like the vowel sound in say it also
has to.
Oh,
sounds open.
off like the Oh and pop and the closed.
Oh,
sound.
like the.
Oh,
and pope and both Spanish and Italian
have a similar role.
Take our sound.
One notable difference between Spanish
and Italian pronunciation is that almost
all Italian words end in a vowel,
but in Spanish,
this is not the case.
For example,
in Italian custody,
which means to cost,
but in Spanish it's goes to the Italian
word,
ends in a vowel while the Spanish word
ends in a continent.
If you watch out for this,
you'll notice it quite a lot.
Pronunciation and orthography in both
Spanish and Italian,
C and g become soft when followed by I
or II,
but the soft sound is different in each
language.
In Spanish,
the soft see sounds like thug or sung.
In Italian,
it sounds like in Spanish,
the soft g sounds like in Italian it
sounds like Joe,
for example,
in Spanish and in Italian to Ta,
this means city in Spanish and it means
people,
but in Italian it's Gente in Spanish,
and it either means general.
In Italian it's Gen ed Ali.
Some words like those above are
cognates.
That sound different.
There are other words that sound similar
but have to be written differently to
reflect their sound.
The word for what in Spanish is k
spelled with q and an Italian.
It's k spelled with a c,
H in Spanish.
If you want to have the hard c sound
before I or II,
you have to spell it as q.
You in Italian,
you have to spell it as c,
h and while c h always represents a hard
c sound and Italian and Spanish at
represents the sound like an English,
so in Italian you have joke gelatto
spelled with cei at the beginning,
but in Spanish you have that day spelled
with C,
h in Spanish you have wonder meaning
when and Glenda,
meaning how much,
and in Italian you have quandl and
quantile.
In Spanish you can't write it with q you
because that always represents a hard c
sound,
so the words would end up sounding like
a and comfortable.
Some of the differences in pronunciation
and orthography between Spanish and
Italian are fairly systematic.
For example,
he in Italian often becomes,
I eat in Spanish for example.
Temple becomes the MPO.
Then day becomes the ending and went an
Italian.
You Have Sc,
SF or sp or st at the beginning of a
word in Spanish.
These are often proceeded by an IEP.
For example,
[inaudible] in Italian becomes as could
to be in Spanish and especially in
Italian becomes a speciality in Spanish.
One other thing to note is that double
consonants are very common in Italian,
but in Spanish most consonants can't be
doubled.
For example,
in Italian got Dole means cat,
but in Spanish it's that the end in
Italian means cup,
but it's in Spanish grammar.
The general word order of Spanish and
Italian is very similar.
Have a look at these two sentences in
Spanish and in Italian,
Louis,
no money,
no money.
You can see that there's some different
vocabulary,
but the sentences are translatable.
Word for word.
Notice that in both languages,
the subject Pronoun is normally optional
because the verb is conjugated for
person and number.
Another example in Spanish or in
Italian?
Well,
your scrotum.
This means I wrote him a letter,
so here hear the word order is still
exactly the same,
and notice that the object Pronoun comes
before the conjugated verb.
In this case,
the auxiliary verbs in both languages.
Italian grammar has a couple of
complications.
That Spanish doesn't have.
Articles,
articles in Italian or more complicated
than it.
Spanish in Spanish.
The indefinite articles,
our own for masculine nouns and owner
for feminine nouns.
Also in Italian,
it's Oona Una,
but boone becomes uno before words
beginning and s or z,
followed by another continent and Una
becomes an apostrophe before unowned,
beginning with a vowel,
so in Italian we have past,
but we student debt and we have key ave,
but when Italiana,
Spanish and Italian,
both have four basic definite articles
in Spanish.
They are for masculine singular law,
for feminine,
singular,
for masculine,
plural,
less feminine,
plural.
In Italian,
the ill for masculine,
singular law for feminine,
singular for masculine,
plural,
and lay for feminine plural,
but it'll becomes low before words
beginning with Srz plus another
continent and it becomes l apostrophe
before a vowel and eat becomes leaky
before s or z plus another continent,
so we have it'll pass support at all,
but law students which are both
masculine singular and we have ipass it,
but the identity which are both
masculine plural,
also both law and lay become l
apostrophe before vowel possessive
pronouns.
The way possessive pronouns are used is
also a little bit different.
In Italian,
possessive pronouns are normally used
together with a definite article except
when we talk about family members,
but in Spanish the definite article is
not required.
So in Italian you have Lamina beachy
collector and it's Spanish.
You have music later,
so notice in Spanish there's no definite
article law.
Another difference to notice here is
that in Spanish there is no distinction
between masculine and feminine
possessive pronouns.
In Italian there's mia for feminine
singular and meal for masculine
singular,
but in Spanish there's just me for both
verbs.
The verb tense is used and the way that
verbs are conjugated is really quite
similar in both languages.
Of course,
the exact conjugations are not quite the
same,
but they are fairly similar.
Here's a sentence,
meaning they will live in New York.
The verb to live in Italian is vivacity
and in Spanish it's Bev is the sentence
in Italian lovato and New York.
In Spanish,
they just maybe then we can see that the
third person,
plural,
future tense conjugation is similar,
but notice that the Italian one ends in
a double consonant and vowel.
Now let's look at a sentence in the
past,
in the present,
perfect.
To be precise,
this sentence means she bought too many
things in Italian layout and it's
Spanish.
Yet the present perfect tense is formed
the same way in both languages.
First,
here is the auxiliary verb,
meaning to have have edit in Italian or
in Spanish.
That's followed by the past participle
of the verb,
meaning to buy [inaudible] in Italian
and in Spanish.
One thing to note about the present
perfect tense is that an Italian,
most verbs take the auxiliary verb,
Aveda to have,
but some verbs take std meaning to be as
their auxiliary verb.
That's similar to in French,
but in Spanish the only auxiliary verb
is I've added meaning to have,
so in Italian there's a in Toronto,
meaning he entered,
but in Spanish it's I am data.
Those are just a couple of examples,
but basically all verb tenses and all
verb forms have an equivalent or a
parallel in the other language bringing
it altogether.
Let's just look at a couple more
sentences and see what we find along the
way.
This sentence means Maria is less
intelligent than her sister in Spanish
as is of manner and an Italian mother.
Men though he did the suicide ella.
Here we can see that the word order is
the same and we can basically translate
the sentence is word for word.
The third person,
female form of the verb to be is similar
but slightly different.
The word for less is similar but
slightly different.
The word for intelligent is similar,
but in Spanish the g sound is softened
to a cup while an Italian,
it's softened to a job and the Italian
word has a doubled l.
The preposition used is also different.
The possessive Pronoun is similar,
but in Spanish there is no gender
distinction and the word for sister is
different in the two languages,
as you can see,
Spanish,
Italian have a lot of similarities
including basically the same word,
order,
similar grammar,
a lot of similar vocabulary and
generally speaking,
similar pronunciation,
but there are still significant
differences,
particularly in vocabulary,
pronunciation and slash or photography.
They are different enough that they are
unmistakably two different languages,
but they're similar enough that there is
a certain degree of mutual
intelligibility and that degree of
mutual intelligibility can probably be
greatly increased by studying even the
basics of the other language,
but producing the other language
accurately is obviously another matter
and that would require dedicated study.
Okay.
The question of the day for native
speakers of Spanish and Italian,
how well can you understand the other
language both in speech and in writing
and have you ever tried to converse with
a speaker of the other language using
only your native languages?
How did that work out and for learners
of Spanish and Italian?
How much does your knowledge of one of
those languages help you make sense of
the other?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and as always I would like to say thank
you to all of my patrion supporters,
especially these ones right here on the
screen for their monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.